[音楽]
誰が馬面やこんにちははじめしゃちょー
ですというわけで今日ですね
富士急ハイランドさんにお邪魔しており
ます昔ですねはじめしゃちょーの畑でも
挑戦したんですけれども皆さん富士急
ハイランドのアトラクション
絶望要塞ってご存知でしょうかちょっとね
ひときわ変わったアトラクションというか
脱出ゲームというか謎解きゲームみたいな
感じのアトラクションがあるんですけれど
もなんとその
絶望要塞
めっちゃ難しいらしいんですよ無理だった
もんねもうめっちゃ難しかった
難しくてもうそのクリア者が出なかったん
ですけれどもなんとクリア者が出たらしく
て
完全リニューアルしたらしいですお
めでとうございます
毎回こうなっちゃうんかな1人クリアし
たら変わってくってなったらすごいですよ
ねすごいよね逆に言うと今まで出なかった
んだっていうそれぐらい超難易度の高い
絶望要塞がついに
完全リニューアルしたということで
ちょっと見てみましょうかはい今もう絶望
要塞の前にいるんですけど
雰囲気なんか全然違うねピンクがモチーフ
になってるというかなんか怖いレスゲーム
始まる感じですねかっこいい
そんなに触れない方がいい体のこの作りと
いうかこの
脂肪の乗り方曲線美かなり美しい芸術張り
の手の向きと
髪型とか造形だいぶ
雰囲気変わりましたね前回なんかもっと
メカメカしくなかった
緑とかグレーみたいなねちょっと洋裁
っぽかったんですけど今回はもうなんか
不思議な世界観というか別世界に来た感じ
になっております行ってみましょうかご覧
ください上絶望要塞インポッシブルゲーム
今日で7月の25日なんですけども
オープンが7月の29日まだオープン前な
んですよでクリアしたらリニアされちゃう
今日で終わらせます
やっちゃいますよ今日すみませんねまだ
あのオープンしてないんですけども
ちょっと初挑戦ということでオープン前に
ちょっと絶望要塞どんなもんかなと今日見
てみたいと思います
絶望要塞ってさこうなんか集団でプレイ
する人もいるじゃん4人ぐらいでなんか
やってますねなんか
チームワークでクリアする人もいりますし
もちろんソロでプレイされる方もいるん
ですけど今回ちょっとソロでプレイしてみ
たいと思いますじゃあ早速行ってみ
ましょうかもうこのZは絶対
絶望要塞のZですね
シャンデリアとかもあるし
多くなんか絵も飾ってあるのなんか世界観
すごいな
[音楽]
ちょっと不思議の国のアリスミがあります
うわぁなんかすごいけどダルマ落とし
みたいなのがある
カイジミというかライヤーゲーム見という
か
闇のゲーム感がすごいな
累計絶望者数と
完全クリア者数
1125分の0まだオープンしてないんで
オープンしたら多分0になると思うんです
けどこれテストプレイとかスタッフの方と
かの
プレイ人数ですねでも1000回やるって
結構やってるよねかなりの人数と回数
プレイしてもまだゼロということで
ちょっとやっていきたいですねこれ始まる
やばい
抜け出したら爆発するやつ
うわやばいガチっぽいぞ
持ち込んだ道具は使わないこと館内の
アトラクションは全て用意されてる道具
のみでプレイ落とし物はしないですごいの
が
クリア者0なのよ
得点が100点に到達するか制限時間
を終了します
[音楽]
ID番号をタッチすると
扉を開けたりゲームを開始したりできます
なるほど
プレイ中に次にダウンするかわからなく
なった
館内の各所にあるカイロミラーを利用して
ください
[音楽]
それではファーストステージの説明を始め
ますお願いしますファーストステージは2
つのゲームを行います
ボーダーラインを超えるとセカンド
ステージに進めます
ボーダーラインに満たない場合は会場と
なってしまいます
ジエンドファーストステージ全体の制限
時間とボーダーラインが表示の通りです
これから行うあみだくじで各チームの最初
のゲームを決め
ます次に出てくる映像の下にあるタッチ
ポイントを選ん
で早い者勝ちです
もう始まってるって事
押さなきゃってこと
これにしようかなこれこれにしますはい
[音楽]
やったー
やったなのかも分からん
ファーストステージに向かいます
わかりました
俺はAってことだね行こうかというわけで
ファーストステージ行ってきます
ABCDあるから
ごめんなさい全部は見せれないな100点
取ればいいって感じですねここか
ファーストステージ行きますえ
怖い
怖いよ
[音楽]
うわぁ
楽しい始まってるけどもう楽しい
あガイドミラーだ行動分からない時はこれ
ピッてやればいいらしいです俺でもAに
向かうであってるよね
100点にしなきゃよし
とりあえずAに向かう
か
あったじゃあ行ってきます
キャッチポイント
入室せよ行ってきます
だるまさんが転んだ
指示された番号のボタンを押せ
ばどこ
誰もどこ
[音楽]
転んだ
だるまさん
だるまさんはころんだ
合ってるかな
[音楽]
めっちゃ近くにあった
ね
次は64
だるまさん
転んだ
やばいどこだえ
ないないです
[音楽]
俺の得点
33点やばいなこれ言われた数字を触りに
行かなきゃいけないよね
33点か
まだある
次で高得点を出せばそうだよね次がいいに
向かえってたんで探してみましょうか
はてなとかあるけど
ビックリマークもあるけど多分ダメだろう
な
どこだ
そして時間制限もあるからね
ありましたいい発見しました
行きますいい
ルールを理解する俺全てのピースを枠の中
に収めようピースはタッチで回転ブラック
でこういうやつかOkOkOk回転の
トラックで行くよパズルゲームね
[音楽]
はいはい
まずい結構やばいかもやばいかもこれ
怖くてでこうしてこうして
うわぁやばいえこれだって回転してさ
入んなくない
これすごいな
やばい絶対違う
考えろ考えろ考えちゃダメだ
えっと
これ違うか違う
か
こうして
こうしてえ違う何かが違うぞ何かが違う
えっとでここはこれで行けるこう
[音楽]
して変えない
急げ急げ
急げ
[音楽]
うわっこれ違うなはいで
これやばい
[音楽]
はいどうもすごいすごい
100点乗ったんじゃない
ラスト
[音楽]
回転させる必要なかったなえっとやばい
行けるか
無理か
やばいこれダメか
70点結構
良くない
100点超えたらクリア
来ました
[音楽]
やりました
ありがとうございます
さっき言ってたところだはてなに迎え
勝てない行きましょうか
これおもろいわやっぱでもうまいから
さっきの直感系
のだるまさんが転んだ的な運動で起きて
ダメだったけど逆にこのパズル系で稼げた
ね
頭も体も使うね
行きますね
何が起きてるんだ
行きます
うわ何これ何これ何これ何これ
制限時間内にこの部屋から脱出せよ入って
きた扉からは出られない次にセカンド
ステージの1に向かい出ろってここから
[音楽]
出ろってこと出ろってこと
するな次はこれガチの緊急避難用のやつだ
どういうこと
なんか書いてるこの模様を探せってことか
これ多分そうだよなそうだよな
緑と黄色がつながってるとこ緑黄あった
ありましたありました開いた開いた開いた
これクリアクリアそういうことですよね
はい
緑色になってるけど
なんか緑色になってるけどなんか色出てた
じゃんあれはヒント下が
黄緑と黄色だったっけなんかもう分かり
やすかったからそれを目印に探しました
次
行きます
気がする
はい
わかりました行きましょうはいすぐそこだ
よねここか
行きましょうか
セカンドステージこれから3つのゲームを
行う
合計得点が108点を超えるとサード
ステージに進める180点に満たない場合
は退場と
しりとりを手がかりに4桁だな暗証番号を
見つけろやばいごめんマジで頭おかしく
なってきた次押す
ね
手掛かりの最初の絵はこれ
絵の下の7が最初の暗証番号になる77
確定でしょ
最初
の文字が濁音半濁音の場合それらを取って
はならない
Aはセカンドステーションのエリアに
散らばっているここってことだよね
セカンドステージは
このモニターの裏にあるモニターで暗証
番号を入力せよ
これだ
で入力しなきゃってことか4桁の数字って
ことだよね
絶対に探しに行けて
絶対の最初に7だよねどこかにヒントがあ
るって事
このエリアの中にあるってことだよね
あったわ
えじゃなかったガイドミラーだったもう
こういうのからヒントもらえないかな
あちゃんと分かりやすく出てくるね
とりあえず絵を探すってことか行くぞ
あー何もないです
積んでなかった
タイヤ書いてあるけど
タイヤの3タイヤ3ちょっと
覚えとこうか対応さん
こういうのが散りばめられてるって事だよ
ね
タコの9
タコの9タコ
切り株オクトパス
豚のにあ切り株の部だ
ってことは次は2か72
727と2はある
どういう順番なんだこれ
あったわスイカの位置もうやばいどういう
ことだということだどういうことしりとり
完成してるんですか
切り株
豚
タコタコタイヤ高校そこまでじゃない
繋げればいいのか
タコタイヤの後に続くものを探しに行こう
か
広いなぁ
違うな
過去タイヤ
かなこれ一応
覚えとこうか
やばい
急げ
今回やでこれ違うこれ
楽器の名前わかんないんだよなこれラッパ
かな
キンパニーか
トランペットタイヤ加工
違うな
そして広いね
迷っちゃうよ
あれこれ
健介
それ違うね
さっきヒントで濁点をなんか抜いてみたい
なことだったからこれタコに繋がる
んですよ
最後ゼロっぽいなってことは
[拍手]
逆算して考えようかまず0が最後ね0最後
0最後
踊りましょうか
タコタコ探しに行こう
迷うのも絶望要塞だよね
0ゴリラ00ゴリラ
0000まず0まず0
やっぱマジで広い本当に広い
タコでタコが9タコの前タコの前
どこ行った
豚豚どこ
頭がかかってきた
豚なんか奥にいたよね
290290290290290290290
よね
で最初は7
でしりとりよね
2907290-7290いけるいける
行きます729
[拍手]
あれ
いや90だったはずだ
1回言ってみる77920
まずい
あと3回間違えたら終わっちゃうやばい
やばい
1回落ち着こうかこういう時に慌てたら
絶望要塞クリアできません
タイヤの線もちょっとタイヤのさん覚え
といて
ダイヤの3みたいな感じ
他の線も残しておいてさっきの楽器が
トランペット
いや関係ないわ
あったえー
滑り台が2だろう
タコ豚何も繋がらない
いや覚えれんこれはこれ一人
脳のキャバが足りないね
そうだね
何かを読み間違えたりとかそうですね知っ
てる可能性はありそう
これやっぱ手間なんじゃないかこれ
もしかして
ゴリラじゃないの
で729だったから
なぜもっと情報を集めよう
こんなのいた
カエルいるんだけど
スイカに繋がるね
切り株
スイカカエルができた
あと部と巣をつなげる何か
ブスって何番です情報
量が多すぎる
ただ絶対まだ見てない札があるのよ
終わりました
つなげろつなげろ切り株
豚
タココアラ
どう
なんですかそれ
切り株豚タココア4でしょ最後読んでる
最後44
で豚が何だっ
けそうだよねやばいセカンドステージ
いただきます7294
ありがとうございました今はクリアして
ますよね多分今クリアしてたね1
階のここだねここに向かいましょうまだ
終わってないということか
だって終わったら普通に大丈夫うち行かさ
れるもんね
エルに向かってことは俺まだ終わってない
ここからここからですまだ生きてるまだ
生きてます
エールありました
じゃあ行きますね何が待ってるんだ
これさっき0点だったけど大丈夫かこれ
失礼します
普通にやるんこれ白い線が出てくるって
こと
四角い枠の外に出ちゃダメってことね行き
ますどこから来るんだろう
お願いしますどこから来ますか
さっき
めっちゃ流行りのきたけど
よしよしはい
なんでどこ
無理無理
音が聞こえる
音が聞こえるなんか
はい
早い
はいはいはいはいはい早いはいはいもう
許して
70点
これ
次は
Rに向かいますか
やばいこれねほんと名の通り心身ともに
強くなるため
だよオックスフォード
辞書と顔文字店
イライラも支持された感じが載っている
ページ番号を使って問題を解けるえどう
いうこと指示された感じ指示されますその
ページの番号を使ってもらえるとき分かり
まし
たね
タイじゃないの
これ書いて読むじゃないっけタイムの回だ
よねこれ
完全苦手なのよ
やばいマジで苦手だこれみんな
やばいやばいまじ時間ないやばい
ステージに
早すぎる
[音楽]
帰ります
あーなるほどね
ここでIDバンドを返却するとありがとう
ございましたタッチしてか
プレイリザルトだ
これで成績がちゃんと出るんですね
マジで皆無
はいというわけで新しくなった絶望要塞
プレイしてみました
悔しいね
悔しいもうちょっと何かできたんじゃない
かってすごい思いますけど
ファーストステージクリアできただけで
ちょっと我ながらに満足してます
パズルできてなかったらマジで終わってた
よ最初でセカンドステージしか見せれて
ないし
取れるから全然まだまだたくさんあるん
ですよ全然まだたくさんあるんですけども
こういう感じだよっていうのが皆さんに
見せれたら良かったですなんか今日はソロ
でやったんですけども3人までプレイ
できるんだよね3人1グループとプレイ
できるのでなんかこう友達とか
賢い人とか謎解き好きな人と来ると
ひょっとしたらクリアできるかもしれませ
んね
バイバイ
[音楽]